elle est restée mauvaise note aura mené
par notre honneur dos au mouvement
on a manqué là ça veut dire rien qu'une
femme juste une femme tout une femme
[Applaudissements]
nos batteries
oui tout une femme pour dénoncer
publiquement l'un des pires maux qui
rongent de lune à vic la contrebande
d'alcool ce marché noir rapporte gros
aux trafics à des dizaines de millions
par année des bouteilles de vodka
achetée à la saq 14 dollars et revendus
illégalement dans le grand nord 550 $ et
parfois plus embêté isis je suis parce
que ça
la revente d'alcool existe au vu et au
su de la saq
les inuits vient du nord en acheter pour
leur vendre là bas puis le 25 entre 5 et
10 fois le prix quand l'alcool de
contrebande débarque dans les
communautés la violence éclate dès que
ça rentre
on reçoit des appels c'est pas des
problèmes mineurs non plus des gens
meurent des enfants perdent leur
naissance des enfants sont violés
les aînés sont violés
ça ça te laisses et des personnes
il n'y a pas de valeur
[Musique]
la chanteuse béatrice lire interprète ce
champ inuit en compagnie d'enfants de
couacs tac son village natal mais
derrière ses sourires innocents se cache
souvent de grandes souffrances
c'est d'abord pour les enfants du
nunavik que béatrice d'hier a décidé de
sonner l'alarmé et de diffuser ce
message sur facebook qui s'en prend aux
bootlegger ces trafiquants d'alcool tout
en maillot no les problèmes d'alcool au
nunavik sont connus ils sont la
conséquence des nombreux traumatismes
subis par les inuits la colonisation des
pensionnats l'abattage des chiens de
traîneaux la consommation excessive
d'alcool
et c'est important de le mentionner ne
touche pas la majorité des inuit
mais les dérives d'une minorité sont
assez graves pour que la plupart des
villages interdisent la vente d'alcool
sur leur territoire ils permettent
toutefois l'achat en ligne d'une
quantité limitée de bière de vin et de
spiritueux
les contrebandiers eux sont ouverts jour
et nuit et faire c'est une
t'as quoi
eminem rabat au pinacle aura mené il
noir n'est pas condamnée et mai à lomé a
cru télé son message a été partagé plus
de 700 fois et a suscité beaucoup de
commentaires tous positifs
il faut beaucoup de sagesse pour avoir
le courage de dire la vérité toute crue
comme tu fais merci d'aborder ce sujet
délicat
on a besoin de plus de gens comme toi un
sujet grave
triste effrayant frustrant nous avons
rencontré béatrice dira quoique tac ce
petit village de 450 personnes situées
du côté de la baie d'ungava béatrice
nous amène au cimetière en haut de la
colline lui et susciter aussi que
l'ajout des jeunes au sort et comme une
vingtaine de 21 celui-ci way à cause de
l'alcool
oui ça c'est un autre processus était
maire ne pouvait pas être aux jeunes
d'abord 16 ans car à cet enfant ça toute
sa vie
ces barres en bois ouais bah t'as cru
c'est vraiment un est mort dans le
ventre de sa mère pendant le père abattu
sa mère était ce sont des gens qui sont
supposés être vivant sont proposés
enterrés ici
parmi toutes ces croix blanche une toute
récente celle de janis 10e sa nièce qui
s'est suicidé elle venait tout juste
d'avoir 18 ans elle avait des problèmes
d'alcool
ouais parce qu'elle voyait les bootlegs
way sur ma sur ma jambe avait tout le
temps
les bootleggers n'hésitent pas à vendre
à des mineurs fin janvier 2019 un
blizzard souffle sur le village de salou
est tout au nord du québec
maggie tayara à 15 ans elle passe la
soirée une partie de la nuit à boire
avec des amis
le lendemain matin son corps
complètement je les ai retrouvés sous
une maison
le rapport du coroner confirme une
hypothermie et une intoxication à
l'alcool et au cannabis
la vodka qui a contribué à tuer magee
avait été acheté chez un bootlegger ou
nunavik près de 75% des actes criminels
sont commis sous l'influencé de l'alcool
les bootleggers on parmi leur clientèle
ceux à qui le tribunal interdit de
consommer on en avait il ya des gens qui
ne sont pas exposées avoir de l'accès à
l'alcool comme des préfets par exemple
qu'elles vont boire il ya des arbres en
partant
le format de 375 mille litres de vodka
qu'on appelle un ami qui est le plus
populaire il se vend 100 dollars soit 7
fois le prix régulier ce qui est loin
d'arrêter les gros buveurs
c'est beaucoup d'argent qui s'envolent
rapidement
alicia lara gut ac en sait quelque chose
elle a vécu avec une mère qui flambait
son argent chez les revendeurs d'alcool
[Musique]
ils ont été mis en avant
non que pose à l'adolescence
alicia va faire exactement comme sa mère
[Musique]
davos genoni
alicia s'en est sorti et elle est
déterminée à offrir à sa fille une plus
belle enfance mais encore aujourd'hui
pour plusieurs enfants au nunavik la
situation se répète
les enfants sont négligés les enfants
enfin parce que l'alcool christ qui est
vendu illégalement est vraiment chère
ses petites-filles mange avec appétit et
le repas que leurs cris paris béatrice
et sont venus voir leurs idoles de
passage à quoique tac
ces enfants sont régulièrement privés de
nourriture
c'est à béatrice que les fillettes ont
confisqué elles vivent à la maison vous
ne verrez pas leurs visages ils nous
avons changé leurs voix afin de protéger
leur identité par hacquard lectorat de
ses sources mais grands parents boivent
aussi des fois j'ai c'est de cuisiner
tout seul je peux maintenant faire du
riz l'alcool c'est aussi toute la
violence familiale qu'il engendre je me
mettais en mai par un quand il se
battait comme j'essayais très forte des
tirs amis parents d'arrêter de boire un
an plus tard et sont retombés temps
alors commencé à boire
mes parents ont dit qu'ils allaient
arrêter mais ils ont continué et tout le
désarroi des fois je suis pas bien
traité je me suis fait dire que j'ai
voulu me suicider vous menez as roma
jérémy menez as roma 3-2
je me suis fait taire
je me mignard au maracanã tel arrêt
allant voter de la musique un peu de
réconfort de légèreté pour ses enfants
avant qu'elle ne retourne chez elle dans
la nuit
[Musique]
la population du nunavik ont près de
14000 personnes sur les 14 villages
trois seulement peut vendre de l'alcool
coup de joie qu elle un petit village il
y a deux bars et le magasin coop permet
à certaines heures la vente de bière et
de vin
la décision de vendre de l'alcool n'a
pas eu d'impact sur le marché noir bien
au contraire
la situation s'est même un graphique
beaucoup trop attendre de plusieurs
façons sa lampe au départ déjà qui
voyagent par 4 go par la poste par
bateau l'été dont il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de points d'entrée c'est ce qui
fait en sorte que c'est très difficile
pour nous de contrer tout l'alcool
illégal qui rate on a vécu
dénoncer la contrebande c'est une chose
dénoncer contrebandiers c'est plus
risqué
pas évident non plus quand le
contrebandier fait partie de la famille
c'est difficile parce que comme tu vois
essayé on est là la colonne puis on voit
presque tout le village pour m'en
informer
une façon à l'eau je suis parent avec un
tiers de ce village
de retour à coude jacques deux jeunes
femmes dont nous tairons l'identité pour
des raisons de sécurité nous montre avec
quelle facilité on peut trouver de
l'alcool illégal une première vendeuse
contacter sur messenger répond dans la
minute le tiroir oui entre
petit trouver une autre place j'en ai
déjà trouvé elle se rend à cette
deuxième adresse
qu'est ce que vous faites dans cher
jamie king jarlet après une minute
juste un oui
[Musique]
un but isis je suis passé jusqu'à ce la
contrebande se fait à petite et grande
échelle la police a actuellement dans sa
mire un bootleg heure de montréal dont
les revenus sont dans les sept chiffres
on connait un on a tous eu il a fait 4
millions $ il a dépensé je pense 60000
effective
en parcourant facebook nous trouvons ce
trafiquant des bouteilles de vodka sont
bien en évidence sur sa page d'accueil
et des billets de banques servent de
photos de profil nous demandons un
collaborateur de le contacter en se
faisant passer pour un client qui veut
acheter de l'alcool l'homme qui dit être
à montréal lui donne des directives bien
précises
le conte où serait la transaction en
question se trouve au cameroun
photos à l'appui il dit envoyer
régulièrement de l'alcool est aussi du
cannabis par postes canada et air inuit
il nous propose d'aller voir le site de
sa compagnie qui vend du cannabis à des
fins médicales mais aussi de la cocaïne
de l'ecstasy et du crystal meth
nous l'avons appelé pour lui demander de
nous accorder une entrevue il a bien sûr
refusé
il nous a fait parvenir ce message bien
senties payan s'adresser à des policiers
d'autres trafiquants recrue des
intermédiaires souvent des inuit pour
faire les achats d'alcool
à montréal ils se rendent surtout ici à
la saq de dorval près de l'aéroport
trudeau où atterrissent les vols en
provenance du nunavik d'ailleurs les
bouteilles de vodka sont bien en
évidence
à l'entrée du magasin nous la saq n'a
jamais voulu corroborer cette
affirmation le monopole d'état nous a
écrit que la divulgation de ces
renseignements risquerait de porter
atteinte à ses intérêts économiques
[Musique]
tous les employés à qui nous avons parlé
dans cette succursale nous ont confirmé
la très grande popularité de la vodka et
la revente de cet alcool ou nunavik à
500 madame comment ça ça sort tout seul
comme un seuil prennent tout sauf
personnellement oui oui ce qu'on voit
ici c'est beaucoup pour la revente le
yach attend à 15 parce qu'ils font
tellement d'argent en vendant ses connus
ceux qui font ça et l'emplacement
valises devant vous au oui il y en a
toutes les deux trois jours il vient
chercher ducasse pour la pub en ligne ou
non un blanc un blanc à chaque de trois
jours je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui
travaille là bas
toujours dans cette même succursale un
homme d'origine inuit remplit son
chariot de bouteilles de vodka
ce qu'il fait est tout à fait légale
mais une fois à l'extérieur de la saq
son comportement est plutôt curieux ils
transfèrent les bouteilles d'alcool dans
un sac et y ajoute des paquets de
bonbons les aliments secs peuvent
masquer des sons compromettants
comme nous le confirme l'enquêteur qui
n'est pas d'amis
les grains café ça sent bon et ça fait
du bruit il pense qu'on ne va pas
s'apercevoir qu'il y à de l'alcool parce
que ça couvre bien le son du liquide
il traverse au bureau de poste et
envoient leurs colis c'est exactement ce
que fait cet homme il transfère
maintenant les bouteilles et les bonbons
dans une boîte de postes canada alors
qu'il est illégal d'envoyer de l'alcool
par la poste
le colis est ensuite déposée au comptoir
il est destiné au nunavik l'employé n'a
rien remarqué
[Musique]
nous voulons à notre tour vérifier c'est
aussi facile qu'on a dit d'envoyer de
l'alcool dans le grand nord puisque
c'est illégal nous remplissons nos
bouteilles d'eau du robinet pour éviter
tout bruit de liquide
nous ajoutons des pâtes alimentaires si
c'était 35 bouteilles de votre cas le
prix régulier serait de 500 $ cette même
quantité pourrait être revendu en
quelques heures au nunavik 3500 $ un
profit intéressante
nous enverrons nos deux boîtes par les
compagnies first air et air inuit et la
troisième par la poste
destination coup jack et kwata verrons
si elles seront interceptés
devancé entrée massive d'alcool
on peut dire que les deux seuls
enquêteurs du nunavik en ont plein les
bras
on a saisi de l'alcool de contrebande
partout nunavik ça ça vient de
saint-louis principalement 8 mais aussi
new jack et beaucoup de coups du wac
la police compte beaucoup sur les appels
anonymes du public pour les aider à
détecter les colis suspects en 2019
le montant des saisies s'est élevé à
près de 800 24 mille dollars
c'est presque le double de l'année
précédente on n'aura plus ce n'est qu'un
aperçu de ce qui se passe là plus
importantes saisies d'alcool au nunavik
a eu lieu en 2018 dans une résidence de
coude jouac la sûreté du québec a
collaboré avec la police régionale
kativik
matthew johnson était l'enquêteur
principal
[Musique]
on a trouvé 29 1000 $ en argent comptant
et je dirais 250 me quitte votre cas où
de rome et 30 caisses de bière sur le
marché noir ça vaut 35 mille dollars
[Musique]
les trafiquants d'alcool est retombé
anne et son fils samy selon la police
vendait aussi à des mineurs ils ont
écopé de l'amendé maximale à cause de la
quantité d'alcool et d'argent saisis
soit une amende d'environ 4000 chacun
s'est pas beaucoup pour tout l'argent
qu'il forme je suis bien d'accord avec
vous des peines qui ne sont pas très
dissuasive
nous avons retrouvé certaines baies and
le contrebandier en question il
travaille dans une épicerie à coude
jacques
[Musique]
une alcool beaucoup plus puissant que la
vodka circulent au nunavik de l'alcool à
94%
c'est satan contiennent chacun 4 litres
l'envoi était destiné au petit village
d'à coups liés ils vivent environ 600
personnes
un flasque de 375 millilitres à 26
dollars se vend sur le marché noir
300 dollars
nathalie bélanger a travaillé comme
infirmière au dispensaire d'acholi vict
sur la côte de l'hudson elle a traité
très souvent des patients fortement
intoxiqué au 94 % des cas d'hémorragie
digestive ou les gens ont saigné en fait
boum 501 alcool qui se retrouvent bien
souvent entre les mains d'adolescents je
devais surtout les jeunes filles et les
femmes ont consommé 10 94 sur sont
retrouvés aussi soient inconscients les
façons le québec est le seul endroit au
canada à vendre de l'alcool à 94% à des
fins de consommation
partout ailleurs il est interdit parce
que trop dangereux je comprends pas
comment ça que qui est une branche du
gouvernement du québec fait pas de
recherche est ce qu'ils sont vraiment
vraiment pas capable de voir qu'il ya
des gens qui vivent illégalement de
l'alcool qui vient de nous on a beaucoup
de gens disent morgen qui achètent des
grosses caisses pitié mais le seul à
bord les employés le savent mais qu'en
est il de la direction nous avons voulu
poser la question la présidente de la
saq
catherine dagenais notre demande
d'entrevue a été refusé la saq a préféré
nous envoyer un courriel
la société des alcools du québec suit ce
dossier depuis plusieurs mois
dès que nous avons été informés qu'il
était possible que nos produits fassent
l'objet de contrebande réponse
surprenante puisque tous ceux à qui nous
avons parlé au cours de notre enquête
ont affirmé que la saq est au courant de
ce problème depuis plusieurs années de
sûreté sa sauce au sol ont été
sensibilisés eu des rencontres dans le
passé avec eux doivent poser la question
pourquoi que la succursale de dorval
autant de ventes de bouteilles dont on a
besoin d'eux ils savent que c'est pour
faire du trafic
ils savent que c'est illégal que c'est
pour revendre
la société d'état nous dit qu'après
avoir pris connaissance du problème
elle a contacté rapidement la sûreté du
québec la saq nous confirme et ajoute
que le dossier est actif
nous avons aussi demandé à la saq
pourquoi elle est la seule au canada à
vendre de l'alcool à 94% à des fins de
consommation
elle a répondu qu'elle a entamé une
réflexion sur la commercialisation du
produit
la saq nous a référé à la régie des
alcools de l'ontario qui elle permet la
vente d'alcool à 94% mais à des fins
scientifiques et médicales
la saq va-t-elle s'inspirer de sa
voisine elle ne nous en dira pas plus
les policiers du nunavik montre aussi du
doigt les compagnies aériennes qui sont
l'une des principales voies d'entrée de
l'alcool de contrebande
déjà qu'ils remontent ce bar leurs
bagages ou même par 4 go c'est faux
c'est aucun aucun screen and sécuritaire
qui ai fait le sait ça aiderait beaucoup
s'il y en avait
[Musique]
oh
sans grande surprise les bouteilles que
nous avons envoyé sont toutes arrivées à
destination
first air et air inuit sont la propriété
de la société makivik makivik protège
les droits et intérêts des inuits et
gère entre autres l'argent obtenu lors
de la signature de la convention de la
baie james et du nord québécois
nous avions beaucoup de questions à
poser à son président charlie watts
monsieur watch n'a pas donné suite à
notre demande d'entrevue notre troisième
boîte a été expédié par postes canada
qui interdit l'envoi d'alcool elle est
arrivée sans encombre au bureau de poste
de coo de joie qu où l'attendaient notre
collaborateur
c'est le courrier de la reine on ne peut
pas y toucher
la police ne peut rien faire sans un
inspecteur des postes et un inspecteur
des postes il n'y en a pas au nunavik
les enquêteurs de la police régionale
kativik aimerait pouvoir ouvrir eux
mêmes les colis postes canada a elle
aussi décliné notre demande d'entrevue
elle a préféré nous envoyer un courriel
ou elle mentionne qu'elle fait ce qu'il
faut pour intercepter les envois
d'alcool et qu'elle collabore avec la
police
elle préfère ne rien révéler sur les
nouvelles mesures de sécurité mises en
place il ya maintenant pour ne pas nuire
à leur efficacité pour l'enquêteur
johnson postes canada pour en faire
davantage
il faudrait faire plus d'interventions
chez postes canada pour empêcher
l'alcool d'entrée sur le territoire
postes canada est une voie d'accès
importante mais on fait une opération
tous les trois mois si on est chanceux
une autre manière de s'attaquer à la
contrebande
c'est d'offrir des services pour ceux
qui souffre d'alcoolisme
ces services sont déficients il n'y a
qu'une seule organisation qui traite les
dépendances ou nunavik
c'est le centre histoire civique à coude
jouac qui peine à répondre à la demande
un nouveau centre construit au coût de
40 25 millions de dollars ouvrira ses
portes fin 2021
c'est alicia aragou tac cet ancien
client des bootleggers qui dirige
histoire civique
à bloquer la femme le programme au yukon
gold procès
[Musique]
il ya huit ans béatrice d eux a dû
quitter son village pour traiter sa
dépendance à l'alcool et aux bootlegger
j'avais des problèmes de colère j'avais
des des pensées suicidaires et il n'y
avait pas de l'ied avoir quand je vais à
rome
c'est à montréal à près de 1800
kilomètres de son village
kébé at rice a reçu toute l'aide dont
elle avait besoin problème c'est que le
gouvernement amène pas des ressources
dans nos régions on ne reçoivent pas les
mêmes services
quelqu'un top canadien cet artiste
engagé multiplie les tribunes elle donne
ici un spectacle pour venir en aide aux
femmes autochtones itinérantes de
montréal
béatrice dire est loin d'avoir dit son
dernier mot
[Musique]
il ya tout le temps de l'espoir
c'est la seule chose qu'on peut faire
comme qu'on peut avoir c'est de l'espoir
c'est trop tôt car tout le monde est ma
mais on est encore vivant quand on est
vivant il ya des polkas de l'espoir
[Musique]
je